verlassene schiffe hilflose seemänner im
stich gelassen von ihren rädern tausende
kilometer von zu hause entfernt und das
hat auch mit deinem konsum zu tun
smartphones klamotten sneakers alles hat
seinen preis und für den werden seh
leute immer wieder ausgebeutet
ihre schicksale recherchieren wir seit
über einem jahr an die explosion von
behrendt sehr schnell wird klar beides
die ausgebeuteten seemänner und die
explosion hängen eng zusammen wenn die
ladung so gefährlich war wäre es besser
gewesen wenn das schiff mit ihr gesunken
wäre
wie es zu der katastrophe im libanon
kommen konnte und was das mit der
ausbeutung von arbeitern in der seefahrt
branche zu tun hat das erzählt dieser
film
es ist der vierte august als in beirut
2750 tonnen ammoniumnitrat in die luft
fliegen die mindestens 220 menschen in
den tod reißen und hunderttausende
obdachlos machen
sieben jahre zuvor bringt die ross die
zerstörerische fracht in den hafen von
beirut wir stoßen auf dieses foto es
zeigt kapitän und bootsmann an deck der
ausschuss im hintergrund die gefährliche
ladung 2013 ist sie auf dem weg von
georgien nach mosambik beladen mit dem
hochexplosiven ammoniumnitrat doch weil
der russische schiffseigner kein geld
für die suezkanal passage hat soll das
schiff in beirut zusätzliche fracht an
bord nehmen um so die durchfahrt zu
bezahlen am 20 november 2013 läuft die
ross beirut an
aufgrund von sicherheitsmängeln lassen
libanesische hafen kontrolleure das
schiff nicht mehr auslaufen der räder
gibt es ein schiff auf lässt die crew
und stich auch die republik moldau unter
dessen flagge die rosskur half den sie
leuten nicht ein verstoß gegen
internationales seerecht aber kein
einzelfall
so kostet der kapitän war für treibstoff
verkaufen um so weiter und so fort
um selber einen anwalt einzusetzen dass
sie sich darum gekümmert hat dass diese
leute überhaupt nach hause kommen und
das alles hier führt zur problematik
dass das ist stärken gibt die einfach
sagen
sagen wir so mehr ickx und du kannst
unsere flagge hinten dranhängen und es
gibt staaten die kassieren tatsächlich
einfach nur das geld und helfen damit es
kostenlosen unternehmer und besatzung
bild bis aufs äußerste auszunehmen und
auch deutsche reeder machen mit nach
monatelangen recherchen finden die
endlich einen seemann der bereit ist mit
uns zu reden
wir treffen ihn im hafen von livorno er
arbeitete auf einem schiff der deutschen
reederei blumenthal das trinkwasser an
bord war nicht kostenlos man musste
dafür bezahlen der preis war davon
abhängig wo wir gerade waren sie mussten
für trinkwasser bezahlen ja manchmal war
nicht einmal genug davon da wir hatten
nicht genügend trinkwasser dabei
da waren vielleicht zehn crewmitglieder
an bord und wir hatten aber nur 20
kisten
wir wollten bezahlen aber konnten nichts
kaufen war kein wasser da war der see
mann aus sri lanka zeigt fotos von
seiner zeit auf dem schiff liter in
tonnen hätten sie regenwasser gesammelt
das wasser sei aber ungenießbar gewesen
der blick in ein glas mit drüber brühe
durchsetzt von schmutzpartikeln über
einen messenger dienst informieren die
seeleute fast einen monat lang
hilfsorganisation über ihre verzweifelte
lage dann eine nachricht verfasst in
einem brasilianischen hafen am frühen
morgen haben wir dann endlich etwas zu
trinken und zu essen bekommen hamburg
hier finden wir das schiff auf dem der
matrose dursten musste die liter
auf unsere interviewanfrage lässt die
reederei blumenthal anwälte antworten
es habe an bord immer proviant und
getränke in guter qualität und menge
gegeben
das hätten behörden kontrollen erwiesen
doch wie kann es auf einem deutschen
schiff zu solchen arbeitsbedingungen
kommen weil es auf dem papier keins ist
denn die liter wurde nach liberia
ausgeflaggt aus flaggen auch bei
deutschen reedern ein verbreitetes
geschäftsmodell
zuerst wird eine briefkastenfirma in
einem billigflaggen land gegründet sie
tritt als eigentümer auf das schiff
bekommt eine neue flagge zb die von
moldau panama oder im fall der liter
liberia an bord geld nun die regeln des
flaggen staates zu meist schlechtere
löhne und eine schlechtere soziale
absicherung die bundesregierung wollte
das ausflaggen bekämpfen
mit steuererleichterungen und anderen
vergünstigungen zählt man alles zusammen
fördert der staat die deutschen
reedereien jährlich mit einem mittleren
dreistelligen millionenbetrag doch
einmal ausgeflaggt kommt kaum ein schiff
zurück fuhren im jahr 2000 noch 38
prozent der schiffe deutscher reeder
unter deutscher flagge waren es 2015 nur
noch elf prozent
die arbeitsbedingung auf hoher see
sollten uns alle angehen denn unsere
handys computer oder klamotten werden
meist per schiff transportiert 90
prozent des weltweiten warenverkehrs
findet auf dem wasser statt
man hat auch keinen vorteil weil eine
deutsche flagge hatte vorsicht ist
öffentlich zu sagen aber auch nicht mehr
deutscher sondern ich habe es für die
deutsche volkswirtschaft vorkommen
der das sagt ist dirk 17 jahre lang bis
2019 war in der geschäftsführung des
deutschen reederei verbandes tätig
heutzutage geht es fast nur noch in die
personalkosten es geht tatsächlich wenn
ich aus frage darum dass die besatzung
der schiffe anders definiert werden kann
von ihrer herkunft her und damit kann
ich geld sparen nicht durch steuern und
das ist standard in der seefahrt branche
wohin das führen kann zeigt die
geschichte zweier ukrainischer seemänner
an der bulgarischen küste am schwarzen
meer
das ist die flagge die bedeutet dass wir
hilfe braucht seit zwei jahren leben
hier die beiden seeleute an bord der
russische besitzer hat das schiff
aufgegeben in varna gestrandet hoffen
sie seither dass der frachter
versteigert wird und sie doch noch ihre
heuer bekommen
bis es soweit ist können sie mit ihren
familien nur skypen
das ist meine ehefrau siehst du alle
wissen es ist total schwer einmal
finanziell und einmal seelisch klar
jeden tag denken wir an dich kenia
natürlich ohne finanzielle hilfe durch
mein mann ist es schwer in der ukraine
zu leben
der durchschnittslohn beträgt hier nur
etwa 120 bis 130 dollar pro monat und
die nebenkosten sind total hoch und
deshalb sitze ich hier und warte auf
mein geld
ihr schiff fuhr unter der billig flagge
des pazifik status palau einmal kam ein
vertreter des landes an bord wir
verstehen das selber nicht als das
schiff festgesetzt wurde kam der
vertreter der flagge von pala kam an
deck und hat alle unterlagen abgeholt
und weggebracht
er hat gesagt falls ihr bezahlt werde es
keine probleme mit ihrem schiff liegt da
wie bringe ich alles wieder zurück
insgesamt schuldet die reederei den
beiden seemännern 71.000 dollar
im fall der russin bei rot ging es sogar
um 100000 dollar an nicht gezahlten
gehältern und hafengebühren die
libanesischen hafen behörden hielten den
kapitän und zwei seeleute für zehn
monate in einer art geiselhaft um so die
schulden einzutreiben
doch der angebliche schiffseigner
tauchte unter und zahlte nicht wir
finden internetforen in denen sich schon
acht jahre vor der katastrophe seeleute
über den russischen räder und sein
schiff beklagen
im maschinenraum herrscht völliges chaos
der besitzer hat das geld für die
verpflegung gekürzt er jammert ständig
dass seeleute zu fressen
dieser schiffseigner hat kein gewissen
den damaligen kapitän der roßmarkt heute
die wut angesichts der katastrophe ich
habe keine ahnung warum es diese
explosion geben musste und ich kann
nicht verstehen warum die ladung so
lange nicht gelöscht wurde
wenn die ladung so gefährlich war wäre
es besser gewesen wenn das schiff mit
ihren gesunken wäre
in beirut haben hafen aufsicht und
politik maßgeblich versagt und so die
katastrophe erst möglich gemacht doch so
lange sich räder weiter hinter
briefkastenfirmen verstecken können und
sich so aus der verantwortung ziehen
besteht die gefahr dass dieses unglück
nicht das letzte gewesen ist
sollte ausflaggen verboten werden
schreibt es uns in die kommentare